[Music]
chuck
at some other point we talked about the
moon yes
now it's time to talk about the sun nice
i guess why not
gotta like the sun you gotta you gotta
like the sun source
yeah there's some life at the bottom of
the ocean right that never gets that
never even sees the sun
i wonder what that's like it lives where
the sun don't shine
that's funny yeah yeah in the wa
in the water where the sun don't shine
so
you know that has me wondering what
happens if you're just a fish
swimming in the water and then someone
captures you
pulls you out of the water into the air
and then there's like land and mountains
and sky
and clouds and and direct sunlight
that's that's that's the closest thing i
can think of to someone grabbing you out
of your dimension and putting you
somewhere else
right but here's what's worse they pull
you out
but then they put you back in the water
right and now you're going around all
the other fish like yo man i'm serious
this really happened to me this happened
to me man okay
like first i thought it was some food
right they grabbed my jaw
it wouldn't let me go i fought and i
fought they pulled me out man
i couldn't breathe i couldn't breathe
man and then it was like
all this light i don't even know what to
call it hurt it hurt like
hell man and it was these things the
fleshy things man and it was crazy
and it was like like you know what you
know what the bottom what we see down
the bottom
except instead of sand it was like sand
but it was real hard and
and it was like puffy stuff above the
sand and it was
oh man uh why y'all dude i'm not crazy
yes you are
you know we're gonna do we're gonna get
someone to animate that that have an
actual fish
speaking those words all right
[Laughter]
so yeah so one of the things they get to
really experience is the sun
and particularly if they live sort of if
they're bottom feeders right the sun is
not a big part of their life really
uh so so let me talk about the sun
the sun is uh you know how far away it
is in light travel time
um eight and something minutes yeah good
good yeah you chuck you know
you're coming along here
so it takes 500 seconds for the light to
reach
earth from the sun so 500 seconds if you
do the math it's 8 minutes and 20
seconds
all right and it's moving at the speed
of light through the vacuum of space
so that's that's kind of cool and but
you know something
earth's gravitational influence also
moves at that speed
so if some giant came along and plucked
the sun from the center of our
solar system we would continue to
see the sun feel the sun
the sun until 8 minutes and 20 seconds
passes
oh and then the party is over over
that's all she wrote
like you ain't never seen a party end
and so what then happens is the planets
one by one
will fling off into interstellar space
and plunge into eternal darkness that is
a needle scratch if i ever heard one
and so we need we need a sci-fi story
where somebody just reaches in and
plucks the sun out
and just watches what happened and and
how we are in our blissful ignorance
for eight minutes and 20 seconds you
know what that's another great short
film
it's like you know it you show that and
then you show
like the beauty of life in real time
of eight minutes and 20 seconds and only
you the viewer knows
that that's that's all over for
everybody to end and by the way they
can't know that any sooner than when
it's too late
because that's that's the rate at which
the information is coming
yeah yeah that's creepy
i love it i love it all right
so the sun i just little tidbits about
the sun so maybe
it might not be something you thought
you knew but it might be something you
glad you learned
how about that oh wow okay all right so
if you hollowed out the sun
so now you just have the volume of the
sun and then i
sort of played a little basketball and
started tossing earths
into the sun do you know how many earths
would fit in the sun
oh yeah i know the sun is huge
compared to the huge i don't know how
many earths would fit
so take a guess how many like 10 100
1000
i will say thousand or give me a number
more than a thousand earths
i'm trying to i'm looking at the scale
models of all the
and uh the things that i've seen okay on
the ceiling of your kids who did the
the planet projects you know
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say a hundred
thousand earths
okay that's a lot of earths right i mean
a hundred thousand earth so the actual
number
the actual number is about a million
what
that's about a million earths damn
a million and so the weird thing is you
go back in time before we had any sense
of anything
and there are people thinking that the
sun is just something else in the sky
but earth
is the earth is the earth is the thing
right
we are the center right and since earth
and the moon are the same
size on the sky earth and the moon had
almost
equal presence in our culture right
there's a moon god and a sun god of
course
you know that there it was and any
illustrations of the two of them they're
the same size because that they look
that way
but they're nowhere commensurate with
each other and it wasn't until much
later that anybody
figured out that the moon does not give
its own light
it is only reflected sunlight
only so there's a geometry of things
going on there
but some of that comes from the bible
where i forgot which
passage but it's and the sun it's in
genesis of course
and god created the sun to light the day
and the moon to light the night
as though they are their own agencies of
of light sources
but that's that's not the case plus the
moon isn't always out at night
uh and most of just an equal amount of
time it's out in broad daylight
as it is out at night so so
i'm just just just saying so so a
million times larger so that is
huge the sun has blemishes which we call
what
sunspots sunspots that's official
they're like liver spots except the sun
has really good skin
[Laughter]
okay so the sun only occasionally has
the liver spots but has a really good
dermatologist this is what you're
telling me
all right so the sun so sunspots
are about the size of earth so the sun
has
acne bigger than earth oh my goodness
yeah yeah that's crazy that's that's
cold that's that's
that's now sunspots even though they're
dark
they have a lot of high energy radiation
so they'll go off a lot of ultraviolet
and even
i think some x-rays i'd have to double
check that when the sunspot
population grows this we say the sun is
active
it's going through its cycles the sun it
has an 11-year cycle
and it's where there aren't many
sunspots and then there's a bunch of
sunspots and then there aren't many
usually zero actually and then it goes
back to is it more movement
i don't know i haven't asked
actually no yes it is more moody during
sunspots yes
because during sunspots not not only is
the sun
radiate more and this affects earth's
atmosphere
the atmosphere absorbs this extra
radiation heats up
thickens and all of our orbiting
satellites now have to boost themselves
more
back to their orbit because it each it
encounters more atmospheric resistance
look at that so that we do that with the
space station with the hubble telescope
and anybody else up there who wants to
stay and maintain
an orbit a stable orbit during solar max
it's called
we're on the walk we're on the lookout
for a decay of our orbits
because this the atmosphere got
thickened by this extra radiation coming
from the system
oh wow that is really easy okay so
that's one moody thing it's it's
messing with our satellites okay that's
one
sun blameable thing what else happens is
there's solar flares
so explosions on the sun and these
explosions the sun is
is a is a magnetically charged gas
right and the word for that is plasma
yeah plasma yeah yeah
so so the magnetic fields are all
entangled in there and during solar
maximum
the magnetic fields become so entangled
they bust out
and when they bust out the particles of
the plasma
like hanging on to that magnetic field
but they get flung
into space and then you get waves of
particles
towards the earth there are always waves
of particles we call it the solar wind
but during these particular moments
would you get a solar flare
oh my gosh this the the level of charged
particles can be so high
it can short-circuit the electronics of
satellites when it reaches earth wow
that's crazy so yes the sun is moody at
that time
i'm just making it clear okay and by the
way solar flares can happen but they
don't always point towards earth
we can see them but the pat the plasma
pie goes out into space
so it's the ones where there's a solar
flare and it's headed towards earth
that we keep track of and in fact nasa
has a whole department
called it's space weather it's a space
weather department that's it it's things
that would affect astronauts
in space and it's not only the sun it's
also is there's anything happening in
the rest of the galaxy
so that's so it's another thing that the
sun is doing oh
one other thing go ahead sunspots are
always in pairs
okay i did not know this and so chuck we
measured it and one would have a
positive charge the other negative
charge so we got magnets
on the sun nice just saying but wait
there's more
okay okay the sun is a big ball of gas
so it's not solid the way earth is
and so it turns out the equator of the
sun
completes one revolution faster than
other latitudes on the sun
so it doesn't rotate as a solid object
look at that because
it's a big ball of gas so the middle
could be going
faster than the tops yes yes just to be
clear
it is always physically going faster
because it has more
distance to travel so even if the sun
were solid
it would be traveling faster the way
equatorial residents on earth
right they're all traveling a thousand
miles an hour we here in the middle
like new york latitudes are traveling
only about 800 miles an hour
due east because they we both complete a
circle at the same time
they went a bigger distance right so
they've got to be traveling faster
okay that's the merry-go-round effect
the outer
horses are moving faster on the merrier
ground than the inner ones even though
it's moving as a solid
rotating as a solid object with the sun
the equator rotates faster
now that here's there's the rub so watch
what happens because the entire ball
is magnetically charged and their
magnetic fields within it
the magnetic field wants to hold on to
the plasma
and the rotating sun says no you don't
i'm going to
stretch you as i what we say
differentially rotate okay and as that
happens the magnetic fields stretch
and stretch and stretch and there's a
point where they can
no longer stay attached
and they snap and this snapping it's a
very complicated
magnetohydrodynamical mechanism but the
disruption
of the orderly magnetic fields are what
punches through to make to make this
the the flares on the surface of the sun
and when everybody punches
out and they get it out of the system
the magnetic fields reconnect
and we start the cycle again oh but wait
uh oh but it's not an uh oh
that's not a oh okay but wait okay oh by
the way the sun has a north pole and a
south pole in addition to all of this
just so you know
okay but when the cycle repeats
the entire magnetic field of the sun has
flipped
oh snap so it's in fact
a 22-year complete cycle not an 11-year
cycle
yeah that is amazing that's the sun is
doing all that while you're sitting out
there you know on the beach
while i'm getting beautiful
it does all that and it makes me look
good too all right so let me i gotta
quote galileo before we run out of time
here
uh galileo said i'm i'm paraphrasing
because he said it more poetically than
i'm about to recount
the sun manages to keep the planets
in their appointed paths yet somehow
manages to ripen a bunch of grapes
as though it had nothing else in the
world to do oh
that's yo that galileo he knew how to
turn the phrase
and my boy was a wine drinker so that's
what he's talking about he's thinking
about
what else you do with the grapes exactly
that's pretty good so that's all the sun
i could squeeze into 15 minutes here so
oh man that was that was enough for you
all right so all right call it quits
there neil degrasse tyson as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you